congratulations first of all on this
honor tonight um you said that directing
and acting together was the toughest
thing you ever did why did you want to
do both in your directorial debut i mean
you're an overachiever we know but come
on it happened this way i didn't set out
to do that but sometimes there's a
moment when you realize that you're
called to do something that's outside of
the dream you even dreamed for yourself
and in that moment i just stepped into
it and like a moth to a flame i said
okay
i'll do it did you think about two like
i'm setting a hell of an example for my
babies right now showing them like what
mama can do she can kind of do it all
and and balance it all and still you
know
be their mama
you know i always know that they're
watching me no matter what i do you know
they're watching me at home when i'm
washing the dishes they're washing me at
home when i'm nurturing them because
they're sick so it's not just because i
do what i do as an artist as an actor
they're always watching me and i'm
always mindful of that you documented um
you know kind of your routine working
out getting ready for this and we saw
how beat up you got but like what was
that training like you're already in
incredible shape but what was that like
oh god it was brutal but it was the most
fun i've ever had i got to work with
some amazing martial artists and learn
from the best in the world jiu jitsu
taekwondo judo wrestling boxing muay
thai like i got to do all these
disciplines by the best in the world and
it was um
the time of my life i see that it's date
night tonight
yes last time i talked to you but he i
just saw him last time i talked to him
he said the most amazing things about
you that had us all swooning so why is
it that you love him so much
i mean because it's fun it's my time it
was finally my time and and the right
one finally showed up